- Welcome back.
I always like to finish up
with something fun that could
make you smile possibly.
This is: What I'm Liking.
(bluesy rock music)
So my friends Blake
Shelton and Carson Daly
you've heard of them, right, anybody?
(studio audience applauding)
Okay, okay.
They have a new celebrity
game show premiering
on USA Network tonight at 11.
It takes place
in Blake's Nashville bar,
Ole Red and get this:
It's all based on bar
games, which is awesome.
It's called Barmageddon.
- These are games that are
basically in your local bar
but they're just bigger and better.
- [Female voiceover] Air Cannon Corn Hole.
(country rock music)
Horse on a Horse.
- I was a cowboy in my previous life!
- [Female voiceover] This is Keg Curling.
- Is that where it's supposed go?
- The first time
in your life you're actually
beating Jimmy Johnson.
(audience applauding as Kelly chuckles)
- We've got Carson on
the line to tell us more.
What's up Carson?
(studio audience applause)
- Cheers! What's up everybody?
Hi, Kel.
- Oh my God, I miss you! I
miss seeing you in person.
- Oh, I miss you so much too.
You know, we work on the
Voice together so much
and I asked Blake once, I said, you know
what is more fun than shooting the voice?
Like, what type of show
could be more fun than this?
And he looked at me and he
said, how about a show in a bar?
And I said, yeah, that,
that, that'd be good.
And he, he's like, I got one.
So let's figure out a show.
And we just put this Barmageddon together.
It's just meant to be pure fun.
And it's wild.
I, I can't believe it's
gonna be on tonight.
- I cannot wait.
I know that you know this
'cause I've told you and Blake this,
but like, I really wanna come and play.
I love competing, I love drinking.
These are both things I'm good at.
I think I excel at these things, but this
this show is a combination
of all these things right?
- Yeah. It's just, you
know, so we have celebrities
we have these episodes with celebrities
and we're putting them against these,
you know, viral sensations.
These people who've had
these misadventures online
and so they're playing for a prize,
but it's really not even about that.
It's just a lot of crap talking
a lot of drinking, a lot of music.
Blake Shelton's band is there and we-
and his bar is incredible.
I mean, we're right on Broadway
in Nashville at Ole Red.
So you've just never really
seen a TV show like this.
It feels like you are in the action.
We have great games.
They're just hyperbolic,
over the top, bar games
that you've probably played before.
And it's just, it's so much fun.
- You have wrestling Hall of Famer
Nikki Bella hosting, right?
- Yeah. So we, you know, this is on USA
which is home to- we're on after Raw.
So we have Nikki, who Blake
and I met trying to figure
out who's gonna be the boss of this show.
You know, we're like the
kind of grumpy old men
like from the Muppets that sit up
in the balcony and just
kind of talk smack, you know
that's kind of what we do.
We get in the action on some of the games.
We're in every episode, so she's,
she's just wrangling and keeping control
of everything and she's
a great, great host.
So we are excited to get her
and Kelly, it's crazy.
I mean, we have a drinking
game show that's gonna be
on television with Blake Shelton.
Who would've thought
we could pull this off?
(studio audience applause)
- Well...
Blake's kind of already been
on a a game show drinking,
so he's got experience.
So he's got something
in that cup going on.
Thank you so much Carson.
I'm seriously inviting myself again.
I'm liking your post.
I love you.
(audience applause)
All right, so everyone
watching, remember to tune
in to Barmageddon tonight
at 11 on USA Network.
This is the point in the
show where we usually
give our guests a thousand dollars thanks
to our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But today, that cash is
going to someone lucky
in our audience.
So, you know the drill people,
it's taped under your seat, if you won.
Check your seats!
(drum roll)
- Oh my God!
- What!?
(audience applause)
(funky guitar riff)
- [Kelly] What's- Ha-ha-ha.
- What is happening?
- Your oh my god was amazing.
You are still in
disbelief that you won it.
What's your name? Where are you from?
- My name's Mark Seleno.
I'm from Massachusetts.
- Oh my gosh, well congratulations!
- Thank you!
(audience applause)
What do you think you'll
do with the money?
You gonna have some fun with it?
- I'm eloping with my fiance
so we'll probably use it
towards our honeymoon.
- Oh congratulations! That's awesome.
(audience applause)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Well, happy marriage to both of you.
Have so much fun in your honeymoon
and enjoy the money.
- Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you to all our guests today.
Idina Menzel, Theo James,
Asi Wind, Carew Papritz,
and 49 Winchester.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, turn and change it.